>> So let's talk about a new
kind of value function, that's going to actually make
that optimization part easier and the learning
part easier. So but it's really closely related
to the stuff you talked about, Charles, so let's let's start with what you told
us. Which is here's a definition of, of you. This is, we're going to define you.
>> Mm.
>> And put you in a box.
>> It's been tried before.
>> It can't be done. All right, so well, you know, if you,
if you're a good dog, I'll give you some pie next. So U,
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] U is defined for each state, the utility
being the state, this is, the long-term value of being in
a state is the reward for arriving in that state,
plus the discounted reward of the future, and what's going to
happen in the future? Well, in the future, to leave
this state we're going to choose some action, then we're going to
take an expectation over all possible next states. And we're
going to arrive in some next state, S prime, and then U
is representing the utility of that as well.
So this is, is recursive and nonlinear, but
we know how to solve this, we can
use things like value iteration to do that. Agreed?
>> Agreed.
>> Alright, and you also said, here's how you can use this quantity to
decide what to do. That the policy in a state S is, well, let's
consider all of the actions we can take to leave that state. We'll look
to what their expected values are, so
we'll iterate over all the possible next states
weighted by their probability of the utility of
landing in the state that we'd end up in.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that, that tells us how to behave.
>> Yes.
>> Alright, so these are, these are the value
functions, well the value function of the policy that
we talked about before. Here's our new kind of
value function. It is sometimes called the Q function. Though,
you know, some people in the know don't like
that. It's, it's called the Q function because it's
the letter Q. But it's, some people have said
that it stands for quality but it's just, it's just
a letter in the latter half of the alphabet, you know, V was taken, U was taken,
you know, W is used for weights, like,
Q was available. So, it was brought to bear.
So, so this is, this is a, a new definition and you can see it's got elements
of the other two. Let me maybe write down what it, it, a way to interpret this.
>> Okay.
>> So, again, here's the, the Q function. And what we're going to think
of this as, is, this is the value for arriving in some state, S.
And this is, you know, this is the reward we
get for, for that arrival. Then what we're going to do is
we're going to leave S via action A. So we're going to add
to that the discounted expected value that we get for taking
action A. It's going to now drop us to some next
state S prime, according to this probability, and once we land
in S prime, we're going to take whichever action has the highest
Q value from there, okay? So that turned out to be
the value for arriving in S, leaving via A,
and proceeding optimally thereafter. Like once, once we get
to a new state, we're going to be choosing the
best actions each time. Does that work for you?
>> It makes sense right, because you could, U is basically defined the
same way. It's the value for arriving
in S and then proceeding optimally thereafter.
>> That's right. And all the, the only thing that we're doing here is
we're, we're basically tying the algorithm's hands
briefly. We're saying, we're going to force
you to leave via ac, via action A. After that, do the normal
thing. But just for a moment I'd like you to just take action A.
>> Mm-hm. Okay, that makes sense. So you
just, you, you inserted basically a, a kind
of, kind of utility step in there that I
assume you're about to use in some clever way.
>> Indeed, yes, this is going to turn out
to be really helpful, because it's going to allow us
to compare the values of different actions without having
to actually stare at the model to do it.